we've got one more super sweet story for
the hour this is what I'm
[Music]
liking it takes utter commitment to
prepare and run a marathon I wouldn't
know but I've heard it does uh 26 miles
is a lot of miles to not drive um so
after all that training it takes a truly
big heart to stop in the middle of the
race to rescue a kitten which is so cute
that's just what one Chicago woman did
at the 20th mile marker stopping her
from breaking her personal best time and
also that's a lot of miles you body's
got to feel heavy at that point to like
add a kitten I don't care how much it
weighs it seems like a lot um and before
the race was over she found that kitten
a perfect new home she did a lot okay
during that race we have that runner on
the line right now along with the mama
of the rescued cat let's say hello to
Sarah and Andrea watching on NBC
Chicago hi Kelly what's up y'all so
Sarah tell us about finding the kitten
okay I was at Mile 20 I'm focused on my
race and I remember running into this
tunnel I'm like okay I have six miles to
go I can get there and I turn to the
left I see this little fluffy cat in a
pile of leaves looking terrified I
remember at that moment it was a
split-second decision and I scooped this
little baby up walking along the course
I'm asking Spectators can you take this
cat I remember seeing Andrea uh in the
crowd she stepped forward and she was so
compassionate she had said I a catmom
myself I will rehome this cat I will
love this cat with all my heart and at
that point I handed him off to her and I
haven't seen him since a well well
Andrea that couldn't have been your you
know checklist of things to do that day
so like what how did that happen so not
at all um I I've been going out there uh
cheering on the runners for like 20
years with my family so it's like a
normal year um um and we were all out
there and This Woman's in you know in
her running outfit and she has this cute
little kitty and is so adorable and
she's asking people in the crowd can you
give it a home and then when we met I
was like um in a split second I thought
to myself can I and I said yes I can we
brought him home um and we're very happy
with him his name's Casper and uh he's
doing very good my my family loves him
the kids love him um and you know we're
just so happy to have him as part of our
family oh my gosh I wish I weren't
allergic they're so cute oh yeah super
cute uh thank you so much Sarah for
having such a kind heart also an
athletic one um and Andrea thank you for
taking the kitty in Casper is super cute
look at the little paw around the oh my
God I'm liking your post right now but
that's not all our season long partner
pilot pin makers of precise the go-to
PIN the Kelly Clarkson show want to
celebrate animal lovers just like y'all
so they're giving you $1,000 $500 each
just for being
rad thank you guys so much and thank you
to all our guests this hour Kevin James
not Charles eston and Elana yall have a
great day and if it's not
[Music]
changing
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home